so people tell me I'm a nice person to
the point where it's part of my personal
and professional identity that I'm so
nice and able to get along with anyone
even my most fierce opponents it's like
my thing it's what I'm known for but
what no one knows is that I was a bully
honestly I didn't think about it much
myself I buried the memories for years
and even still a lot of it's really hazy
denial by the way apparently is also one
of my things but the more people started
to praise me for being a liberal who
could get along with conservatives and
the more I wrote articles about being
nice and gave talks about being nice
more I felt this hypocrisy creeping up
inside me what if I was actually really
mean when I was 10 years old there was a
girl in my class at school named Vicki
and I tormented her mercilessly I mean
everyone did even the teachers picked on
her it doesn't make it any better does
it Vicki was clearly a troubled kid she
would hit herself and give herself
bloody noses and she had hygiene
problems big hygiene problems but
instead of helping this girl who was
plainly suffering from hardships in her
life we called her sticky Vicki I called
her sticky Vicki
my clearest memory is standing in the
empty hallway outside the fifth grade
classrooms waiting for Vicki to come out
of the bathroom and I have a clipboard
and a pen and a survey I've made up
asking about shampoo preferences like
I'm doing a study for science class or
something and when Vicki comes out of
the bathroom I pounce on her and I asked
her what shampoo she uses now to put
this in perspective I can't remember the
names of my teachers I can't remember
the names of any of the books I read
that year I pretty much can't remember
anything from fifth grade but I remember
that Vicki told me she used white rain
shampoo clear as yesterday like it just
happened and there's classes let out I
ran down the hall shouting at all the
other kids sticky Vicki uses white rain
shampoo don't use white rain shampoo or
you'll smell like sticky Vicki I forgot
about this memory for a long time when I
finally started remembering it I
immediately needed to know more I
reached out to friends and eventually
social media and I did everything I
could to try to find Vicki I needed to
know that she was okay and then I hadn't
ruined her life but what I quickly
realized was I wasn't just trying to
figure out what happened to Vicki I was
trying to figure out what happened to me
when I was 10 years old I treated
another human being like some worthless
other like I was better than her and she
was garbage what kind of a nice person
does that I mean I know I was only a kid
but not all kids do that most kids don't
do that right so what if I wasn't nice
after all I was really just a hateful
monster then I started to notice myself
having these mean impulses thinking mean
thoughts and wanting to say them
admittedly most of my main thoughts were
about conservatives
but not just conservatives I also caught
myself thinking mean things about mushy
centrist liberals and greedy Wall Street
bankers and Islamophobes and slow
drivers because I really hate slow
drivers and as I catch myself in these
moments of hypocrisy either they were I
was just noticing the more or they were
getting worse especially in the last few
years and as I felt more hateful a
rageful really I noticed the world
around me seemed to be getting more
hateful too like there was the steady
undercurrent of hate bubbling up all
around us and increasingly overflowing
so the plus side I guess is that I
realized that hate was not just my
problem which is like the most selfish
plus side ever because now instead of
just my own hate and cruelty to try to
figure out I had a whole world of hate I
wanted to unravel and understand and fix
so I did what all overly intellectual
people do when they have a problem they
want to understand and I wrote a book I
wrote a book about hate spoiler alert
I'm against it
now at this point you might be thinking
yourself why are you worried about hate
yet hidden hey Vicky bullying isn't hate
isn't it
Gordon Alpert the psychologist who
pioneered the study of hate in the early
1900s he developed what he called a
scale of prejudice at one end are things
like genocide and other bias-motivated
violence but at the other end are things
like believing that your in-group is
inherently superior to some out-group or
you know avoiding social interaction
with those others isn't that all hate I
mean it wasn't an accident that I was a
rich kid picking on a poor kid or that
Vicky it turns out would eventually end
up being gay poor kids and gay kids are
more likely to be bullied even by kids
who also end up being gay I mean I know
there was a lot going on in my little
ten-year-old mind I'm not saying hate
was the only reason I picked on Vicky or
even though I was consciously hateful or
anything but the fact is the people we
discriminate against in our public
policies and in our culture are also the
groups of people most likely to be
bullied in school that is not just a
coincidence
that's hate I am defining hate in a
broad way because I think we have a big
problem and we need to solve all of it
not just the most extremes so for
instance we probably all agree that
marching down the street chanting about
how you should take away rights from
some group of people because of their
skin color or the gender we'd all agree
that's hate right okay what if you
believe that a group of people is
inferior but you don't say it is that
hate or what if you believe that a group
of people is inferior but you are
aware that you believe it what's known
as implicit bias is that hate I mean
they all have the same roots don't they
in the historic patterns of racism and
sexism that have shaped our history and
still infect our society today isn't it
all hate okay I'm not saying they're the
same thing just like I am NOT saying
that bullying and being a bully is as
bad as being a Nazi just like I'm not
saying that being a Nazi is the same
thing as punching a Nazi but hating a
Nazis still hate right
what about hating someone who isn't as
enlightened as you see what I learned is
that we all are against hate and we all
think hate is a problem we think it's
their problem not our problem they're
hateful I mean if I think the people who
didn't vote like me are stupid racist
monsters who don't deserve to call
themselves Americans alright fine I'm
not being nice I get it what I'm not
hateful I'm just right right
brah we all hate and I do not mean that
in some abstract generic sense I mean
all of us me and you that sanctimonious
pedestal of superiority on which we all
place ourselves that they are hateful
and we are not is a manifestation of the
essential root of hate that we are
fundamentally good and they are not
which is what needs to change so in
trying to understand and solve hate I
read every book and every research study
I could find but I also went and talked
to some former Nazis and some former
terrorists and some former genocide
--all killers because I figured if they
could figure out how to escape hate
surely the rest of us could let me give
you just one example of the former
terrorists I spent time with in the West
Bank
when Bassam arimin was 16 years old he
tried to blow up an Israeli military
convoy with a grenade
he failed fortunately but he was still
sentenced to seven years in prison when
he was in prison they showed a film
about the Holocaust up until that point
Bassam had thought the Holocaust was
mostly a myth he went to go watch the
film because he thought he would enjoy
seeing Jews get killed but when he saw
what really happened he broke down
crying and eventually after prison
Bassam went on to get a masters degree
in Holocaust Studies and he founded an
organization where former Palestinian
combatants and Israeli combatants come
together work together try to find
common ground by his own account
Bassam used to hate Israelis but through
knowing Israelis and learning their
stories and working together for peace
he overcame his hate Bassam says he
still doesn't hate Israelis
even after the Israeli military shot and
killed his twelve-year-old daughter a
beer or while she was walking to school
Bassam even forgave the soldier who
killed his daughter that soldier he
taught me it's just a product of the
same hateful system as he was if a
former terrorist if a terrorist can
learn to stop hating and still not hate
when their child is killed surely the
rest of us can stop our habits of
demeaning and dehumanizing each other
and I will tell you there are stories
like the Psalms all over the world plus
study after study after study that says
no we are neither designed nor destined
as human beings to hate but rather
taught to hate by the world around us I
promise you none of us pops out of the
womb hating black people or Republicans
there is nothing in our DNA that makes
us hate Muslims or Mexicans for better
or for worse we are all a product of the
culture around us and the good news is
we're also the ones who shaped that
culture which means we can change it the
first step is starting to recognize the
hate inside ourselves we need to catch
ourselves and our hateful thoughts in
all their forms in all of us and work to
challenge our ideas and assumptions that
doesn't happen overnight I am telling
you right here it is a lifelong journey
but it's one we all need to take and
then second if we want to challenge the
hate in our societies we need to promote
policies and institutions and practices
that connect us as communities literally
like integrated neighborhoods and
schools that by the way is the reason to
support integration not just cause it's
the right thing to do but because
integration systematically combats hate
there are studies
that teenagers who participate in
racially integrated classes and
activities reduce their racial bias and
when little kids go to racially
integrated kindergartens and elementary
schools they develop less bias to begin
with but the fact is in so many ways and
in so many places around our world we
are separated from each other in the
United States for instance
three-quarters of white people don't
have any non-white friends so in
addition to promoting those proactive
solutions the other thing we need to do
is upend the hate in our institutions
and our policies that perpetuate
dehumanization and difference and other
izing and hate like systems of sexual
harassment and sexual assault in the
workplace or are deeply racially
imbalanced and deeply racially biased
criminal justice system we need to
change that again it will not happen
overnight it needs to happen and then
when we connect together in these
connection spaces facilitated by
connection systems we need to change the
way we talk to each other and connect
with you on another and relate with
generosity and open-mindedness
and kindness and compassion and not hate
that's it
I doubt solve it all right that's it
that is pretty much there's a few
details but that's pretty much all we
have to do it's not that complicated
right but it's hard the hate that we
feel towards certain groups of people
because of who they are or what they
believe is so ingrained in our minds and
in our society that it can feel
inevitable and impossible to change
change is possible just look at the
terrorists who became a peace activist
or look at the bully who learned to
apologize to her victim the entire time
I was travelling around the Middle East
and Rwanda and across the United States
hearing these unbelievable stories of
people in communities who had left
entire histories of hate behind I was
still looking for Vicky it was so hard
to find her in fact that I hired a
private investigator and he found her I
mean he sort of found her the truth is
it became clear that the person I'm
calling Vicky had gone to extraordinary
lengths to hide her identity but anyway
a year after I began my journey I wrote
Vicky an apology and a few months later
she wrote back I not gonna lie I wanted
to be forgiven
I wasn't I mean she offered me sort of
conditional forgiveness here what she
wrote was messages such as yours cannot
absolve you of your past actions the
only way to do that is to improve the
world prevent others from behaving in
similar ways and foster compassion and
viki's right which is why I'm here thank
you
[Applause]